Landy.
Hello!
Happy Friday!
Yeah.
Okay.
Ketan.
Hey, Tim is on here any second.
Sure, thank you.
I mean, I seen him in the office here, so he's...
Should be on any second.
No problem. How are you doing today?
Good, it's a Friday, so I think I'm caught up for the week. Just some invoices to do and...
Then I'm good for the week.
Hey, Team.
Oh, there he is.
Hey, Team, how are you?
Tim can hear us.
Can you hear us now?
Yes, I can.
We can't hear you now.
All right, great, great.
Two.
So, how's it going?
Alright, how are you?
I'm good, good.
Ready for the weekend?
Right.
Ready for it. We'll see.
Yes.
Yep.
Any plants?
No, no, just like hanging around you.
No, this household stuff, yeah.
So we have Andy with us today from the customer experience.
Kip.
Hoh.
Haight.
Alright, so how are things going with Mohit?
All right. We just have one thing to make sure we get nailed down, which is phone calls. We're working on our on our phone system as we speak, I can think, to make sure that we have open hours addressed. And we want to make sure that he's in the queue to get those phone calls when they come in. So expect an email from me when we have that ironed out too, but we want to make sure that he's in the queue.
Okay.
We also have an internal representative here that's going to be manning the phones too, so we want to make sure both of them are aligned with getting the phone calls when they come in.
Yes, 7 to 8 hour time, we have somebody here and then Malig, and then before 7 AM, it's only Malig. Now, Zade can step in and assist if needed, but we want to make sure Malig is the primary.
Okay, sure, no problem.
Any other feedback you want to share?
No, he's been doing correct amount, the email migration we've been given him here, and I know we have one that's kind of in the works. There's kind of rescheduling on us every every other week here for us. So, aside from that, we have a bunch of beam backups that we're going to kind of have him kind of assist with getting these.
you know, situated here with Vaid here. And then behind that, we have some unified updates we're going to tackle next. So it's just making sure that we have.
any kind of knowledge gaps, you know, for that, we'll kind of fill them in with what we know and then we'll go from there.
Okay, okay, sure.
All right.
So that being said, I think we can quickly jump into the presentation and let's look at the numbers.
Sure.
You can.
Let me know once you are able to see my screen.
Yep.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our monthly business review. And this is starting April 13th till May 11th. That is last week.
Hoh.
There is no change in the agenda, so we started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, and recap.
Give me after life on the end.
If I do my Mac computers, like if you go again.
And we already discussed how things are moving, how he's doing, and thank you for sharing the insights and feedback.
I'm right now.
Kip.
Allow me to, allow me to.
OK.
It's possible, but sometimes it gets so long.
So, in the highlights, we have been getting good feedback from Will Kip, and we also confirmed the positives end user CSATs. He worked on multiple firewall patching and activities.
And then.
It is.
Mhm, yeah.
Yeah, and even if you send that here, I cannot guarantee you that, like, because that's what that that's what that's like.
And also proactively worked on the SSL VPN security hardening initiatives.
Like, I have all the options, like, to sign in with.
He also assisted in the critical hunters area incident.
Have a 10, if I, if I was phone and then followed his.
And.
Discussing about the KPIs, any interaction, any progress?
Not quite yet. We had a few incidents over the last couple weeks here, so we'll have to pick that back up, but not just yet here.
So, expect something soon, but just not yet.
Okay, sure. Thank you.
But...
Play that.
And we received the CSAP for Mohit for the month of April. Thank you for sharing the same thing.
Mhm.
So moving on to the action tracker, KPI reporting, that's again on track. It's in progress. And then training and certification on MD102, he's still working on it. He will be completing it by the end of May. He's scheduling the exams.
Kip.
So, yeah, that's in progress.
These are the ITBD recommended KPIs.
Let's jump into the performance analysis. So this is his utilization for the last four weeks. So his average utilization now for those four weeks had been 75%. In the second week, there is a drop and that was due to some periods that he had planned.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
But now, overall, he was able to, I mean, keep the utilization above 70%, so...
Any question on this, Tim?
No, not this time.
All right. And this is his tickets closure. So he worked on 81 tickets in those four weeks. And that makes 20 tickets per week on an average.
And the lower closure rates, again, it's due to the project work and the migrations and interest spaces.
Mm.
Yes.
Any question on this, Tim?
Nope.
All right, so moving on to the way forward, he is still working on converting recurring issues into permanent fixes using automation, AI, and SOPs and awarding and regarding the ITBD KPIs score card. So
She, ohh, you're up.
Okay.
Mhm.
Let us know in case you have, if you need any help regarding that, so feel free to reach out.
Oh, this is the AI by design.
So, and this is Build It Live 2026. Andy, you want to take this over?
Definitely. Thank you, Kip. And Chad, Tim, any plans to visit Build It? That's from August 3rd to 5th.
Yeah.
Can you just see? Oh, you will be. Okay, perfect, perfect. So you might be getting emails about the agenda and all. Or shall I brief you? Okay, okay, you're getting that. Perfect.
I will be, yep.
Correct.
Yes.
Mm.
Yep, I do have a few questions. So I know that you're putting the AI Summit at the end of the week leading up to the Build It event. Okay, I know Tim is going there. I did receive this email from Natalie, it looks like. Just didn't quite understand all the pieces of the puzzle. Anyways, Tim will be there for sure. I don't think I am going, but
Mhm.
The AI Summit leading up into it. What's the details with that? I think it makes sense for either Tim or I to go or both of us to go, but I guess what are we going to do to tack that on the front?
As of now, the complete agenda is not out. You will be receiving that on email. The tentative plan is on Sunday, 2nd of August, there will be a dinner at Sunny's place. And on Monday and Tuesday, 3rd and 4th, it will be build it. And on 5th, that Wednesday, it will be AX later.
Pre.
and there will be a networking event on at New York Stock Exchange. So that's the plan as of right now. The complete agenda for AIX later is still not out. You will be receiving that on email.
OK.
So the AI is not before build it, it'll be after build it.
On 5th, it's on 5th.
Mhm.
Wednesday.
Well, okay, so it's tail and trailer. Okay, that makes sense.
The laptop.
Thank you.
Back to Kip.
Thank you, Andy. So this is a team GPS. So, and that's it. Anything additional, Tim, you want to share? Any questions, any feedback, suggestions?
All right.
No feedback just yet. We are introducing this AI agent called PIA. So we're going to be happy to update Malki with how this works here for onboarding users, offboarding users, things like that. It's pretty neat what it does. It's an AI feature. I don't know if you've heard of it or not, but integrating with ConnectWise, so it's going to be a little bit of
And.
Yeah.
The.
Getting familiar with what it is, what it does, and how we're using it, so...
Yeah, it's a chatbot, right? So, basically...
Yes, it does a little more, but.
Yeah, yeah.
Um...
Yeah, I would call it closer to being a competitor roost. So it's roost, but not as complex, simpler, but using AI. Actually, the AI is very small. So the AI is more of a converting what the customer says into action so that the ticket can be created correctly. That's about the extent of the AI.
Okay.
Mhm.
So it's actually more of an automation tool set, more than an AI tool set.
D.
Mhm.
OK, that's great.
Great. So I guess that's all we have for today. And in case you, Tim, you face any issues, register to the builder, do let us know. You can email me and Andy and we can walk you through the process.
Kip.
Alright, sounds good.
Okay, so thank you for joining. Yep.
One question, Tim. Have you received the link for Hotel Block? Do you need that? Okay, yeah. Okay, perfect, perfect. Thank you.
Yeah.
Yes. No, I got that. Yep.
We're good. Awesome.
Okay, okay. Okay, great. So thank you for joining this call today and have a wonderful rest of the day and weekend.
All right, you too, Kip. Thanks, Andy. See you guys. Bye.
Thank you. Happy weekend. Bye-bye.
Thank you. Bye-bye.
Yep, bye.